cook that's what I do and certainly for
many people for most people who know me
whether it's on television through book
and so forth I'm defined by my my
culinary identity that's who I am and
that typed my canary culture certainly
and that culture is expressed in in
ritual like we go I go mushrooming in
the wood or or fishing for frog or
playing lawn bowling you know which is
petanque or bullied friends and those
ritual in term of expressed very often
in tradition traditional recipe like
certain type of dishes which good with
those occupation and all that so it's a
kind of down the line culinary culture
for me and certainly that's what I tried
to instill in my daughter because
cooking is extremely important for us it
defined as I sell self and I could quote
ladies trust they will say that the
process of cooking in the process by
which nature is transformed into culture
and I think from it's a very profound
statement because that's what we are and
so many of the deal so many of what we
do upon around the table what I have at
home with my wife we sit down together
I've been married 41 years and it's a
ritual that we've done for 41 years
where we sit down and share a bottle of
wine and eat at night but then I may do
a simple roast chicken salad and so
forth now that what you may call country
country cooking you know and then if she
called me and I'm at the market and she
said I just saw such and such and I told
him to come over for lunch or dinner so
i may add a garnish to that or to
garnish to my menu i may put another
bottle of wine on the table and maybe a
nap king and the chicken I'm ad glazed
with a little bit of white wine and some
mushroom and that become bourgeois
cooking and by the time i deglaze it
with cognac and I a truffle with it and
we put flour on the table and we put
some pine is still the same chicken but
that odd cuisine you know so very often
the deaf
of cuisine is marginal to the cooking
itself you know it involve all the
things I think that in my case will
probably remember the catastrophe that
you have a great success that you are
and otherwise you know one goes into the
other there is never a dish which is
absolutely perfect you know there it can
earn some time you get close enough that
you're very satisfied with yourself but
again it has to do with your own palate
without any question if you decide on
the 10 best restaurant in New York or
the 10 best restaurant in front and if I
go to those 10 restaurant five maybe
five six of them I'm going to think are
absolutely extraordinary two or three of
them I'm going to sing they up quite
good and a couple of them i'm going to
say i don't understand why those people
are three star and what I'm saying there
is that you cannot escape yourself so
the four or five that I absolutely adore
just happened to coincide exactly with
my sense of taste with my sense of
aesthetic so it's purely a narcissistic
reflection if you want on my own taste
because that coincide with what I like
and the other one I'm not as familiar
with it so and I said to a certain
extent you can work with many from
people but you cannot escape yourself at
some point you are who you are and that
will be expressed in the food that's
what I try to tell the student at BU for
example i have a class of 10 12 student
hands on and i do a class of two hours i
say i'm going to do the perfect meal for
you today a roast chicken a boiled
potato and a salad it has to be done
exactly the right way basting the right
way the salad has to be cleaned out the
right way so i'm at the right
temperature with the right dressing the
right oil with the right amount right
temperature the potato has to be done
this way and so forth fine so they do
that they tested then they go to the
stove and do it now they have two hours
to duplicate my dish by my three dish
and I always said don't try to be
original don't try to up do one another
to don't try to be different than so
what else because you are different and
whether you like on that for the
better or for the worse I am going to
have 10 different chicken a couple of
them practically perfect a couple cold a
couple undercooked a couple undercooked
occur but whatever they will be
different because you are different and
you cannot escape yourself so you don't
have to torture yourself to sign that
dish to make sure that people know
you've done it because it will be
different anyway granted certainly 34
years ago you know a dimeric and eating
like forcing you know eating hotdogs
frankfurter I mean Frank further a
hamburger fried chicken and maybe can
macaroni or one of those thing and you
do have people what you make all the
more crowd will eat those type of dish
and repeat over and over and over and
over again so in that context that type
of cleaner a spectrum if you want it's
very limited compared to what you are in
Europe for a European conversely however
if you're in a place like New York and
one night you eat Turkish and another
night you eat thailand is and another
night with Chinese and French and
Italian and so forth your spectrum of
taste is going to be much larger than
most European because I've even though
there are you know Chinese restaurant
another kind of a you know different
type of cuisine restaurant in front
ethnic restaurant yet 99.9 to a sort of
French people eat French ninety-nine
point nine percent of Italian did
Italian and so it goes in Germany and so
forth and in Belgium because that part
of the tradition that's part of a almost
something that you're born with you know
something which is visceral something
which and power of sitting down at the
table with the family and for all of
those years so it built up that type of
culinary culture a liar
Oh